Die ganze Liga kann komplett nervös werden. Wir werden das nicht. In dieser Folge entlässt niemand seine Trainerinnen. Versprochen. Über die neuesten Entwicklungen in der 2. Liga, den Hamburger SV und Eintracht Braunschweig spreche ich jetzt mit Thomas Hürner von der SZ und Thomas Löwe vom Eintracht Podcast gegen gerade.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Marc-Graf, Martin Marc-Graf.
Und das 1-0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, was für zwei Wochen oder was für eine Woche auch schon. Ich denke, keine Liga auf dieser Welt hat so viel Geltungsbedürfnis wie die 2. Liga der Männer hier in Deutschland. Gut, außer ich vielleicht mit meinem Zwang in jeder Folge hier, egal wie und wann, einmal meinen eigenen Verein zu nennen. Sorry, not sorry. Ich hoffe wirklich, die Strichlisten existieren. Ich bin Eva Lottabolo und ich begrüße euch sehr, sehr gerne zu einer neuen Ligatour zur 2. Liga. Und bevor ich meine Gäste begrüßen darf, ein ganz kleines bisschen Housekeeping. Denn der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, payone- und sponsorenfrei, finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Spenden. Und lieben Dank an alle, die bereits Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen sind und vielleicht auch die, die es noch werden möchten. Aber an die, die es sind, da geht es stellvertretend heute ein Dank raus an Einarinho, Tillmann SCF, Marta aus Freiburg, Globara Night, der unterstrich Bohem und Gigi1985. Und in dem Zug auch nochmal die Erinnerung. Bitte denkt ganz, ganz, ganz doll an die Kontoumstellung des Rasenfunks. Und dass ihr nicht mehr ganz so viel Zeit habt, eben die Kontoverbindung zu ändern für eure Daueraufträge. Infos dazu auch nochmal in den Show Notes. Außerdem sind ganz, ganz viele Sendungen online. Unter anderem ist auch heute eine Ligatur noch zur europäischen Ligen entschieden. Es erscheint noch ein Schwerpunkt zu Bayer Leverkusen. Also ihr habt bis zum Wochenende ganz, ganz viel nachzuholen. Jetzt kann man aber starten. Und ich hoffe einfach jetzt schon, dass es nicht zu wahnsinnig großer Verwirrung kommt. Denn ich habe jetzt direkt zwei Thomas in diese Sendung eingeladen. Ich sag gleich noch, wie wir das gleich im Verlauf der Sendung regeln, damit ihr als HörerInnen und ich auch nicht so verwirrt werde. Zum einen darf ich mal wieder Thomas Hürner in dieser Runde begrüßen. Ihr kennt ihn bereits als Nordexperte und vom SZ Podcast und nun zum Sport.
Weil du vorhin nach einem Gamechanger bzw. Saisonchanger gefragt hast mit Blick auf dieses Braunschweig-HSV-Spiel, war das andersherum vielleicht dann auch so ein bisschen so? Ja.
Also der glückliche Sieg gegen Pada Born war so ein bisschen okay. Jetzt haben wir mit dem Trainer, also haben wir den Trainer nicht verlängert. Stimmt ja nicht. So haben wir den Trainer nicht rausgeworfen, also gegen jegliche Branchengewohnheit. Mit Glück hat das Team das zurückgezahlt, indem es also wirklich nicht durch fußballerische Mittel, sondern durch puren Willen dieses Spiel irgendwie gewonnen hat. Muss wirklich sagen irgendwie. Also das ist ein Spiel, das musst du nicht gewinnen und das zeigt eine gesunde Mentalität in diesem Team, dass sie das geschafft haben. So und mit dem Wissen plus offenbar einen sehr ausgeklügelten taktischen Plan, wie eigentlich schon im Hinspiel. Und dieses Glauben, okay, durch Wille. Und wenn wir das so machen, wie der Trainer uns das sagt, so ein neuer Ansatz hinten dicht, schnell umschalten. Wir haben ein kompakteres Mittelfeld, dass wir drei Defensive da haben. Hinten stehen fünf. Mit dem richtigen Personal, das musst du erstmal überwinden. Und ja, dann, ich glaube, dieses 1 zu 0 von Bell Bell, das war wirklich so dieser That's Click gemacht in der Birne. So, aber selbst der Anschlusstreffer von Selke, also früher ein Gegentor, brach das Team gefühlt jedes zweite Mal halb auseinander. Und genau, Eva, wie du es gesagt hattest, das Gegenteil war, die haben einfach stuhl ihren Plan weiterverfolgt, haben weiter dran geglaubt und haben dieses wunderschöne dritte Tor dann hingelegt, was für mich– ich habe das in der Gegend gerade in meinem Podcast ein Gesamtkunstwerk genannt, weil das alles so unfassbar leicht aussah, aber alles andere als leicht war, dieses Tor. Und das hat– ja, das war so ein Game-Changer. Und ich glaube, der Zeitpunkt war wirklich das 1-0 von Belbel, wo wir sagen, okay, das funktioniert heute irgendwie.
Ja, das war eines der Spiele– es sind gar nicht so viele, glaube ich, in der Saison, die ich nicht im Stadion verfolgt habe. Habe ich nur dann im Fernsehen geguckt, wo ich mich gefragt habe, wo hat eigentlich Braunschweig so diesen Mut einfach auch hergenommen? Der war auch irgendwie über den Bildschirm hinweg zu greifen. Also ich bin jetzt wirklich kein Braunschweig-Experte oder so. Ich sehe sie auch ehrlich gesagt nur sehr, sehr selten spielen. Aber damit habe ich sie jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht unbedingt zwingend in Verbindung gebracht und gerade dann in den Volkspark zu fahren und ja so einen Auftritt hinzulegen.
Das ist das, was ich etwas ausschweifend gerade versucht habe zu erläutern, auf den Punkt gebracht. Jetzt weiß man, wer hier der Journalist im Raum ist. Genau das, Thomas, der Mut. Weil es gab Situationen, das 2 zu 0. Das war natürlich ein Glückstreffer, gar keine Frage. Dass Jäcke seine alte Form wiedergefunden hat und riecht, wo kann ich auf einen Mann gehen und einen Ball erobern. Das war erst mal individuelle Qualität. Aber dass er dann ganz energisch den Weg nach vorn gesucht hat, das ist neu. Und das ist auch genau das, wo keiner so richtig eine Erklärung für hat. Wo kommt dieser Mut auf einmal her? Weil das typische Spiel– ich hatte vorhin darüber geredet, dass wir lange Spiele keinen erkennbaren Offensivplan hatten. Und da sah oft so aus, entweder lange Ball auf Polter oder Chabo nach vorne, oder wir wissen eigentlich nicht so richtig. Das gipfelte darin, dass einer wie Philipp, der nun Raum vor sich braucht und anspiele, dass er einen Gegner vernaschen kann oder in den Sprint gehen kann, dass er sich Bälle aus dem defensiven Mittelfeld geholt hat, weil vorne einfach nichts mehr ankam. Typischerweise war das Spiel alles andere als vertikal angelegt. Idealtypisch, dieser Lauf von Jäckl hätte früher nicht stattgefunden. Er hätte abgestoppt, erstmal nach hinten spielen, erstmal Ball sichern. Und wo das herkommt, das weiß kein Mensch. Das ist wirklich so ein Schalter umgelegt. Wir spielen jetzt mal mutig. Ich weiß, ob es verreckt nicht, oder ob es auf einmal herkommt.
Ja, sehr perfekt für die Zuhörer. Ich kann den HSV nicht erklären, du kannst Eintracht Braunschweig nicht erklären. Es sind irgendwelche größeren Mächte.
Wobei ich da in der glücklicheren Lage lag.
Aber sind wir mal auch ganz ehrlich, am Ende des Tages ist es ja auch schön, weil wir alles durch einfache Erklärungen zu erklären werden. Wow, perfekt.
Versteht uns nicht falsch. Ich genieße das gerade absolut.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das natürlich auch mit reinspielt, aber ich glaube, der Vorteil, den man irgendwie auch hat, das ist ja auch so wie, ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren damals auch war, dass so ein bisschen mehr auch große Teams da unten mit drin stecken. Also klar ist Braunschweig einfach qua Liga-Zugehörigkeit seit einigen Jahren. Auch wird einem ein bisschen was erwartet, gerade eben gegen die Aussteiger von unten, die sich jetzt trotzdem gerade 16, 17 und 18 belegen. Aber weil du eben auch so Schalke und Hertha da unten mit drin hast, hat man glaube ich vielleicht da wirklich so psychologisch doch den gleichen, den kleinen Vorteil gehabt, dass eben doch mehr auf die Vereine gucken und dass die sich da meistens, also dass die ja auch bis jetzt quasi noch, oder auch Darmstadt, also du hattest mehr auch von diesen Teams, die sich vor der Saison was ganz anderes vorgestellt haben oder die einfach woanders hin müssen auch. Klar, das beschreibt jetzt nicht vollends den eigenen Spielverlauf, aber ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass das irgendwie, dann sagst du ja okay, aber im Vergleich zu denen, haben wir eben doch ein bisschen weniger zu verlieren und können ein bisschen mehr probieren. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das vielleicht auch noch ausschlaggebend, und du hast halt ehrlich gesagt gesehen, also so viele Trainer-Entlassungen haben halt auch trotzdem nicht gewirkt. Also das muss man ja einfach noch sagen. Also ja klar, Ulm hat einen Trainer entlassen, Regensburg hat einen Trainer, gut, Ulm, also mit Ulm und Münster müssen wir eh so ein bisschen rausrechnen. Aber guck dir doch härter an, guck dir, Darmstadt steht im Endeffekt auch wieder da, wo sie damals mehr oder weniger ihren Trainer entlassen haben. Klar, mit einer bisschen besseren Form auch in manchen Spielen, aber trotzdem, so richtig geholfen hat es ja irgendwie auch nicht. Und dann muss man natürlich auch sagen, von den allen verfügbaren Trainern, ich weiß, dass ich das sehr häufig hier sage, aber erst mal musst du den passenden Trainer finden und der muss auch zu dir kommen wollen. Und du musst das Finanzielle noch beachten. Also es ist immer so, ich verstehe mal alle Seiten, ich war auch etwas fassungslos darüber, gebe ich auch gerne zu, weil ich ja auch meine persönliche Beziehung zu Daniel Scherning habe. Aber ja, also da muss dann ja auch, ich glaube, wenn dann so eine komplette Mannschaft da steht und sagt so, ne, ne, wir packen das aber auch mit dem. Das ist halt psychologisch, again, das Wort, aber das ist halt ein unfassbarer Vorteil, den du dann hinten rauslässt.
Ja, also dass das nicht untergeht. Ich ziehe alle Hüte, die ich jemals hatte, vor Daniel Scherning, also dass er in der Situation so ein Turnaround hinbekommen hat, obwohl er so angenockt war. Wie gesagt, ich ganz persönlich hätte ich die Entscheidung treffen müssen. Ich hätte ihn gehen lassen, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Wie wir heute wissen, es gibt deswegen Leute, die für solche Entscheidungen bezahlt werden und nicht von außen schlau quatschen. Was vielleicht eben auch ein Glücksfall war, ist, dass dann eben die großen Teams kamen, weil es liegt uns halt, nicht den Ball zu haben. Also gegen Regensburg kommt prompt, haben wir mehr Ballbesitz, kommt da nichts mehr raus. Ist dann ein defensiv starkes Team, die auch sagen, nimm mal einen Ball. Wir sind hier die Umschaltmannschaft. Wir suchen das Spiel nach vorne über Umschaltmomente, geht das prompt in die Hose bei der Eintracht. Das kommt uns an der Stelle da halt auch entgegen. Dass ein HSV, ein paar der Boren, die eine Super-Spielanlage haben, auch Kaiserslautern bis zu einer gewissen Weise, die auch mit Acha und solchen Leuten oder auch Ritter superstarke Leute in der Offensive haben, das kommt uns entgegen. Wir stellen uns dahin, verteidigen stark, kriegen den Ball und können umschalten. So spielt ein Gegner à la Braunschweig gerade voll in Probleme. Deshalb bin ich jetzt mal sehr gespannt. Das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf, gut, die wollen auch aufsteigen. Die müssen vielleicht was machen. Das kommt uns wiederum eher entgegen.
Du hast gerade schon gesagt, das geht gegen Düsseldorf, danach gegen Elbersberg. Also zwei Teams, die durchaus noch ein Wörtchen mitzureden haben am Ausstieg. Elbersberg haben wir auch noch gesagt. Die haben, wie ich weiterhin finde, eine der attraktivsten Spielanlagen der Liga. Das geht immer so ein bisschen unter. Aber da bin ich auch gespannt, weil sie dann ja trotzdem nicht so der klassische Ausstiegskandidat sind. Also wie das Spiel wird, könnte ja für beide Seiten brutal wichtig werden. Also für Elbersberg im Ausstiegskampf und für Braunschweig im Abstieg, obwohl man ja auch sagen muss, sollte man das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf gewinnen, kann man ja eigentlich sagen, es ist ja fast die Sache durch.
Wenn wir es dann noch verkacken, wären wir selber schuld, ja. Aber ich meine, ich habe einen hohen Respekt vor Düsseldorf. Also wenn wir da nicht verlieren, wäre schon viel gewonnen. Klar, schlafe ich nachts ruhiger, werden wir das gewinnen, aber das wird verdammt schwer. Ich fürchte nämlich gegen Elbersberg, da bin ich nicht ganz bei dir, Eva. Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich so der Underdog, der einfach nichts zu verlieren hat. Wenn die einfach Bock haben, jetzt mal den Rest der Liga zu ärgern, denke ich, Mensch, prima, die da oben, die kriegen alle das Nervenflattern. Wenn wir nicht aussteigen, ja, wäre zwar schade, aber es rechnet ja irgendwie keiner mit uns. Also die haben, glaube ich, noch am ehesten Bock aufzusteigen, Spiele zu gewinnen und haben am wenigsten zu verlieren von allen, die da oben noch umschwören.
Ja, also zur Einordnung, ich meinte damit halt nicht der, also einer der großen Namen, also eben kein Köln, HSV, Metteburg, in dem Sinne, also die man vielleicht eher vor der Saison dahingesetzt hat und die dann natürlich auch von Anfang an mit einer anderen Spielanlage und mit einem anderen, ja, Selbstverständnis in dieses Spiel gehen, als es vielleicht andere Mannschaften machen. Also das war, deshalb sage ich, das wird vielleicht anders als die Spiele bisher. Aber also ja, also ich bin tatsächlich gespannt und eben als letztes, als Saisonabschluss Nürnberg, für die geht es da um nichts mehr. Also das können wir jetzt ja einfach, also ergehen, ja, rein rechnerisch ist da noch viel möglich, ich weiß, aber ich würde halt trotzdem sagen, die sind für mich da raus, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich würde wirklich spätestens bei Karlsruhe mit 47 Punkten, würde ich da tatsächlich den Cut machen, weil ich das einfach noch nicht sehe, dass Mannschaften mit mehr als 3 Punkten den Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz da wirklich noch spielen, weil dafür sind da zu viele Mannschaften drin. Das gehört nämlich noch dazu. Ja, also da bin ich schon gespannt.
Schamant ist halt, am letzten Spieltag nehmen sich Münster und Umgänge, die Punkte weg. Also das kommt auch noch ein bisschen entgegen. Wobei Dinge oder Mannschaften spielen für Eintracht, unsere DNA ist so, dass das dann alle verkacken. Also bevor es nicht rechnerisch feststeht, gebe ich hier keine Entwarnung.
Ja, das ist sowieso immer besser, sich nicht auf irgendwelche Eventualitäten zu verlassen. Wir wissen alle, wie sowas laufen kann. Aber ich bin mal gespannt, weil ich glaube, Düsseldorf, die haben halt enorm gestruggelt. So gegen Ulm, gegen Münster, gegen Regensburg auch, wenn ich mich da jetzt richtig erinnere, in der jüngeren Vergangenheit. Also sie ist Münster-biel, glaube war ganz katastrophal über weite Strecken. Also ja, da bin ich auch mal gespannt, wie das wird. Aber generell, lass uns mal einmal schon so ein bisschen, weil also ich glaube über den ganzen Saison brauchen wir jetzt nicht nochmal zu gucken, weil das haben wir mit Anna auch schon zum Teil gemacht. Und wie du auch schon gerade gesagt hast, rein faktisch gesehen gibt es ja auch viele Sachen, die irgendwie dann auch lange nicht gut liefen. Man hat sich jetzt eben entschieden, mit Daniel Scherling erstmal weiterzumachen und sollte am Ende der Saison– ich spreche es jetzt aus, damit du es nicht aussprechen musst– wenn der Klassenerhalt steht am Ende der Saison. Ist ja trotzdem so ein bisschen die Frage, wie geht es denn im Sommer weiter? Macht man mit Daniel Scherling nochmal weiter, der dann wieder Last Minute oder mehr oder weniger Last Minute den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat und man jetzt glaube ich drei Jahre hintereinander immer zum Ende raus, dann den Klassenerhalt gerade noch so gemacht hat? Oder was passiert denn im Sommer? Weil also Stand jetzt, was aus der dritten Liga hochkommt, ist bei allem Respekt vor den drei Vereinen, vor Regensburg, Münster und Ulm, doch nochmal was anderes, wenn man statt jetzt sagt, es kommen irgendwie Dresden, Bielefeld und Cottbus hoch. Ja, alleine von der Stahlkraft durchaus nochmal was anderes, als das bisherige. Also was, zurück zu meiner Auskunft, was ist der Plan für den Sommer?
Ja, was ist der Plan? Die ganz große Gefahr ist, dass mit einer Klassenerhalt tatsächlich eingetütet wird, dass sich alle mal wieder auf die Schulter klopfen und sagen, na guck mal, haben wir doch wieder gut hinbekommen, wir wollen eigentlich nicht groß das ändern. Also, wenn man mal ein bisschen weiter zurückkommt, guckt seit 2018, dem damaligen sehr überraschenden Abstieg aus der 2. Liga, ging es ja hoch her bei der Eintracht, also rauf und runter, Berg- und Talfahrt, mit allerdings auch sehr vielen Tätern. Seit dem letzten Aufstieg ist ziemlich viel falsch gemacht worden im Verein. So, ich meine, du sagst es ja zu Recht, auf den allerletzten Drücker tüte nochmal wieder ein Klassenerhalt ein. Der gemeine Braunsteig-Fan sehnt sich nach so einem Mittelfeldplatz, so einer Saison, wo wir einfach sagen, hey, wir werden mal 11er oder so was, oder allzu große Abstiegsnöte. Es wurde eigentlich versucht, jetzt endlich mal im letzten Sommer, überhaupt mal ein Konzept zu entwickeln, nämlich, okay, wir holen mal verstärkt jüngere Spieler, die man entwickeln kann und später dann verkaufen kann. Das bringt uns auch unsere etwas maroten Finanzen vielleicht auch wieder in Ordnung und bringt uns perspektivisch in die Lage, auch mal wieder investieren zu können. Das ist halt durch den katastrophalen Fehlstart sofort wieder einkassiert worden. Das heißt, Daniel Scherning hat zwar junge Spieler gehabt, die hat aber nicht eingesetzt. Wir haben auch eine Menge Verletzungspech nach hinten raus in der Hinrunde gehabt, das muss man auch fairerweise dazu sagen. Aber es ist auch wieder die Situation, was natürlich auch richtig ist in so einer Situation, dass du dann Leihspieler holst. Dann hast du jemanden wie Tempelmann, einen riesen Glücksgriff. Aber natürlich setzt du dann auf diese bewährten Hautdegen, statt dass du da weiterhin junge Spieler einsetzt. Also der einzige, der jetzt so ein bisschen mehr Spielzeit bekommt, ist Max Marie. Das heißt, wir stehen eigentlich wahrscheinlich vor dem nächsten großen Umbruch vom Kader in der nächsten Saison. Ein bisschen besser, weil wir ja neue Spieler geholt hatten, die dann vielleicht auch mal wieder fit bleiben. Wir haben allerdings eh im Verein offensichtlich ziemige Unruhe. Die Warren-Schwester-Zeitung hat darüber jetzt mehrfach berichtet, dass der Aufsichtsrat da sich nicht grün ist, dass da Fraktionsbildung ist, dass bei der letzten Mitgliederversammlung eine Aufsichtsrätin nicht entlastet wurde, die dann so halbherzig, so halb vor die Tür gesetzt wurde, nämlich eigentlich gar nicht. Die war dann zwar nicht mehr Mitglied des Aufsichtsrats, ist aber weiter beratend tätig gewesen, hat auch Zugriff auf Freikarten gehabt und und und. Also eigentlich alles mitgenommen, was man an Privilegen genießt. Der Aufsichtsrat war offensichtlich auch treibende Kraft damals bei der Freistellung von Michael Schiele, obwohl er einen Klassenhalt geschafft hatte unter dem Vorwand, das ist Vorwand unter der Maßgabe, naja, er habe das Team ja nicht weiterentwickelt. Seitdem ist eigentlich immer noch nichts in Sachen Weiterentwicklung passiert. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Also wenn Daniel Scherling es schafft und jetzt offensichtlicher schafft, auch spielerisch die Kurve zu kriegen mit dem Team, fände ich es fair, ihn weiter zu beschäftigen, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Das ist für mich ganz persönlich, wer aufmerksam zugehört hat, eine 180-Grad-Wendung, aber ich würde sagen, okay, der hat dann am Ende sehr spät nachgewiesen, er kriegt es doch hin, was ich ihm nicht mehr zugetraut habe. Gibt es uns verrecken keinen Grund, jetzt ihn zu entlassen und einen neuen Trainer zu holen, nochmal ganz von vorne anzufangen. Der hat jetzt seine Erfahrungen gesammelt, gibt ihm die Chance, macht da weiter. Wie das im Kader wird, wir werden eine Reihung für lieb, wenn wir die Klasse halten, verlängert sich der Vertrag automatisch um den Jahr, den werden wir für Braunstucker Verhältnisse relativ teuer verkaufen können. Dann besteht zumindest eine Chance, jemanden wie Tempelmann zu halten und vielleicht noch mal die eine oder andere Verstärkung zu holen. Sicherlich auch Benni Kessel, das ist jetzt seine erste Saison als sportlicher Leiter gewesen, wird jetzt auch seine Erfahrungen gemacht haben, darf auch Fehler machen, da ist er noch jung genug zu. Wenn er aus ihnen lernt, was passieren muss, es muss jetzt wirklich mal im gesamten Verein ein Konzept sichtbar werden. Wo wollen wir hin, was tun wir dafür? Was wollen wir mit der langsam marode werdenden Infrastruktur machen? Haben wir eigentlich sonst irgendwie eine Strategie mit diesem Verein? Weil das ist seit Jahren ein Leben von Hand in den Mund und die Fans haben darauf keinen Bock mehr. Wir sind wirklich, egal wann, immer 20.000 im Stadion, egal wie scheiße das Team spielt, bis auf so Ausnahmesituationen wie gegen Hertha, wo dann wirklich auch das letzte Mal der Kragen geplatzt ist, immer Unterstützung im Stadion, immer Langmut. Aber so langsam, Leute, müsst ihr mal liefern. Das muss passieren im Sommer. Und wenn das nicht passiert– und ich fürchte, mit diesem Aufsichtsrat wird das nicht passieren. Es läuft gerade eine Mitgliederversammlung, da kann ich nicht beiwohnen, weil ich gerne bei euch zu Gast bin. Ich bin gespannt, ob da die entsprechend mal unangenehmen Fragen auch mal thematisiert werden. Weil das Kommunikationsverhalten des Vereins ist unterirdisch seit Langem, also die Verlängerung mit Daniel Scherling, das war ein Fünfzeiler von Benni Kessel, mehr wurde da nicht gemacht. Da wurden solche Krisen überhaupt nicht moderiert. Es wird totgeschwiegen, was ein Kritik von der Braunschweizer Zeitung kommt. Und Leute, so geht es nicht weiter.
Ich finde es ja schon immer interessant, so unterschiedlich die Position und auch die Tabellensituation beim HSV und bei Braunschweig ist, dass man doch immer wieder sieht, dass da so grundsätzliche Fragen doch gestellt werden. Also was ist denn der langefristige Plan? Also wir müssen ja auch alle ehrlich sein, so fußballromantisch wie wir sind, zum Teil sind halt Fußballvereine doch in einem gewissen Fall halt Wirtschaftsunternehmen. Also natürlich, aber halt mit der Besonderheit, dass die Mitglieder da immer noch das in der Theorie das letzte Wort haben. Und also natürlich großes Dankeschön, dass du trotzdem bei uns bist und nicht bei der Mitgliederversammlung. Das ist klar, aber wie wichtig das auch nochmal ist, dass man wirklich da auch einfach nochmal der Appell, wenn ihr Mitglied im Verein seid, dann geht, außer ihr sitzt bei mir im Podcast, dann geht zu diesen Mitgliederversammlungen, geht zu den Jahreshauptversammlungen, so heißt es bei uns zumindest. Und ja, einfach ehrlich gesagt, um einmal auch raus aus der eigenen Fanbubble zu kommen, das ist ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig, glaube ich auch. Also, weil wir alle unsere Bubble haben, wenn man vor allem auch einfach nur Fan ist, oder vielleicht das so journalistisch nicht so begleitet. Und ja, nehmt halt einfach teil daran. Stellt kritische Fragen, organisiert euch da irgendwie, dass man das schafft. Weil ich glaube, es ist einfach, wir sehen zum Teil, wo das hinführen kann, wenn so was übernommen wird. Ganz, ganz liebe Grüße an 1860 München. So, und Co, also das ist, was da abgeht, ich glaube, das wäre Stoff für 80 Tribütengespräche für Max. So ungefähr, weil einfach da, ne, da merkst du einfach, faktisch haben die Mitglieder da halt einfach, wenigen noch mehr mitzureden. Da kann, also nächstes Mal geht es einmal bestimmen, wer sich, wer ihnen was da einabkauft. Und wenn es ihm nicht gefällt, dann behält er ihn. Super Idee. Ne, aber das ist einfach, also einfach der Appell. Macht's. Geht zu den Mitgliederversammlungen. Ich weiß, es macht keinen Spaß, auf einem Montagabend da 5 Stunden zu sitzen. Habe ich alle schon gemacht. Ist richtig uncool. Ist auch oft richtig cringe in manchen Momenten. Aber es ist trotzdem den großen, großen Vorteil, den wir egal, ob es 500 Mitglieder oder 50.000 Mitglieder sind, den wir einfach haben. Und ja.
Ich an der Stelle, sorry, weil du gerade 1860 München sagst, ich muss einmal Fremdwerbung betreiben, sei mir erlaubt. Es gibt einen sensationellen Podcast von der Süddeutschen Zeitung über 1860 München. Außerhalb des Rasenfunks der beste Podcast über Fußball, den ich je gehört habe. Also ich habe das so gefeiert. Ich habe es so geliebt. Thomas, gerne noch mal weitergeben. Kompliment an die Kollegen da. Fantastisch. Also wirklich, das hat Riesenspaß gemacht, ihn zu hören.
Der ist wirklich sehr, sehr gelungen. Also auch von mir eine dringende Hörempfehlung. Sehr, sehr gut. Könnte man auch mal über den HSV oder so machen.
Ja.
Stoff gibt es genug.
Und in den Show Notes verlinken. Weil, also, Podcastempfehlungen nehmen wir natürlich immer gerne.
Gut.
Löwe, liegt dir irgendwas noch zu deinen Löwen? Ich musste einmal den Wortwitz machen. Liegt dir da noch was auf dem Herzen? Entschuldigung.
Jungs, bringt das Ding über die Ziellinie. Ihr schafft das. Ich glaub wieder an euch. Ihr habt es geschafft. Ich glaub wieder an euch.
Das ist doch– it's the hope that kills you, ne? Um es frei nach Tetlas zu sagen. Sonst würde ich tatsächlich sagen, befinden wir uns am Ende dieser durchaus wieder langen Folge. Ich hab's am Anfang gesagt, es wird niemals passen, dass wir in der vorgeschriebenen Zeit fertig sind. Die Liga ist schuldig. Alle schuld, geht jetzt einfach nur noch an die Liga. Ich sehe mich unschuldig hier. Ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz herzlich für diese fantastische Runde. Einmal an Thomas Hürner von der SZ. Schön, dass du mal wieder dabei warst, um über den HSV zu reden.
Sehr gerne. Er hat mich auch sehr, sehr gefreut.
Und dann auch lieben Dank an seinen Rasenfunk-Debüt und für das Rasenfunk-Debüt an Thomas Löwe. Danke, Thomas, dass du auch da warst.
Danke schön. Aber ganz herzlichen Dank. Und ich hoffe, ich konnte Anna ja, würde ich vertreten.
Ich sag mal so, auf jeden Fall, weil ich hab die letzten Folgen sehr gerne auch mit Anna gemacht. Aber du warst auf jeden Fall eine würdige Vertretung. Und bevor ich euch jetzt in diese Folge entlasse, hab ich noch zwei Podcastempfehlungen, beziehungsweise zwei Medienempfehlungen an der Stelle. Einmal Sport Insight über Heinz Krügel und seine SS-Vergangenheit, aber auch um und wie das aufgearbeitet wird. Und eine ganz klare Höherempfehlung auch in Bezug auf die Aufarbeitung der NS-Arbeit in den Vereinen. Das finde ich eine große Empfehlung. Und auch da die Info, wenn es sowas bei euch im Verein noch nicht gibt, organisiert euch da auf jeden Fall. Der Kicker hat zum Beispiel unter anderem seine Online-Archivien einfach mal zur Verfügung gestellt. Und dann, weil es leider irgendwie im Thema ist, ist auch noch der Hinweis, dass Ruben Gergeco hat einen Text geschrieben über Rechtsextremismus und Fußball. Auch das ist ja immer wieder ein wichtiges Thema. Und daher auch dazu eine Empfehlung. Und wie gesagt, ich verlinke auf jeden Fall noch den 1860 Podcast.
In 1860 heißt er, ja.
Und auf jeden Fall auch nochmal, weil wir darüber jetzt so wenig gesprochen haben, aber eure Podcastfolgen Löwe mit Thorsten Lieberknecht. Für alle, die den nochmal mehr sehen wollen. So, jetzt bin ich hier aber auch wirklich durch, mit meinen Nerven bzw. mit meiner Fähigkeit, gerade Sätze rauszubringen. Lieben, lieben Dank fürs Zuhören. In zwei Wochen sitzt hier wieder Marc. Ich kann euch noch nicht sagen, welche Vereine. Es werden sich wieder irgendwann in Spotlight bringen. Aber bis dahin, viel Spaß mit Fußball, bleibt gesund und macht's gut.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.